great chance for Lucas Raymond turnover Rayman
save comry two big Saves by comry in the early
going nice pass to Peta Dillan cousins in the
middle cousins off to a slow start offensively
this year remember 31 goals pass in front and Alex
lion makes his first big save of the game that one
in front turned over great opportunity com with
a big save Here Comes Dylan Larin onehanded Taps
it in valeno on the for check it'sit samelson
Raymond's also in there Puck still in play Larin
shot score holy snikes what a shot from Lin that
puck might have been Airborne when he ripped it
into the top right hand corner cry thinks the
puck hit the net and we might take a look at
this yeah it's Puck's going to come in the
zone and buffalo might have something here
it looks like as this Puck comes around you can
see the battle down low the samon hits that you
can see Buffalo almost stop playing thinking that
hits the net but there's no whistle Puck pops out
to lurin and he absolutely fires this one one
time you see him go down to that one knee get
the leverage but Buffalo definitely stops thinks
there should be a whistle there isn't and it's in
the back of their net here's o ma to the net
tipped in front going and power nice play to
get it out of trouble David pan back to Shane
gosar looking for a lane he can rip it so can
pan passes down low pass in front it's loose
score Robie fabry knocked down earlier gets
back up and gets his eighth goal of the year in
just his 12th game and once again the Sabers are
down two nothing Detroit just keeps on pushing
here it's going to be cop going to bring this
all the way back to the point but as this Puck
comes back down low you're going to see David
pan he's going to gather this Puck behind
the net watch one two stick checks nobody
takes the body for Buffalo it's just stick check
pan walks to the middle of the ice there gets it
back cop to the front and then again nobody
takes frag in font you got to take the body
there Here Comes Conor Clifton JJ PKA
in front shot oh big save by it l and
the they're leading to great a chances when
you lose those Puck battles you're going to
lose some obviously but to continue to do
that oh what a save penalty coming up on
the Red Wings John Jason Peta he's on a 33g
goal Pace here in the early going olison aoso
he's got olon in front of the net pass across
Shadow what a save by lion on Benson comes up
to Dalene Dalene nice pass here's a poo from
J Dalene Jose dangle oh off the crossbar off
the bar now still two nothing here in Buffalo
Sabers tilted the ice but couldn't get one past
Alex lion shot from the point oh redirected
between his legs save by comry from Lucas
Raymond Johnson whacks it at valeno but it comes
to cider to Brak it Fab's open fabri
can't find the lane cider fires and
scores oh cider playing his 187th consecutive game
at the start of his wings career the 22-year-old
gets his fourth of the year and makes it three
nothing the reason they were so tired earlier
in that sequence cider keeps the puck in they
had a chance to clear every time you keep that
puck in you get a chance to clear it usually
ends up in the back of your net and F with a
great there great patience and cider comes over
the top and gets all of this one almost 100 for
for the weekend we were hoping tonight Dalene
wrap around and good job by lion to go post the
post and calmly make the save boy as he playing
with confidence yeah L has made some really huge
shaves in this game as probably have talked about
it enough buo has some great a opportunities right
in front of the slot and then that one from
Dalene who shows off his skating ability he's
got a penalty coming up here short there come the
wings save by Comon Lin who drew the penalty it's
going to be JJ Peta his patience when he has the
on the power play he almost forces you to make a
mistake or open up a scene cuz you can't wait
that long and shot pass gos bear is it in or
not they say no it looked like it was over the
line from Comer but right there it is waved off
no goal yeah D ch's done a good job of still
attacking they're not sitting back with this
three nothing lead they're still pinching down
the wall their d man trying to force Buffalo into
turnovers they've done a good job after taking
that lead little line juggling there here com Dr m
score Michael rasm with his third of the year
and it's four nothing Detroit R M's going to
find this angle here it's going to start with
gper it's all on a controlled breakout great
pass up through the middle and Ras newon
goes five hole on comry you see heads up
the whole way doesn't stick handle almost
Surprises comry with that five hole shot
welld deserved though he is an absolute stud
here we go he break away for sprong to make
it five nothing oh nice play by comry sprong
had him beat just couldn't bring it to his
forehand power play Buffalo score Rasmus
darene with a missile from the right Point
giving the Sabers some life down
by three 103 to go in the second
who else but Ras stalen off of the face off and
it's just going to be a fake one timer right back
to him and almost looks like Skinner might have
got a piece of this in front of the net he was
actually in my top three on my card and he is a
legit doit all guy who makes it four to one big
save by conry there on Ras M they keep it here's
Bera now he's a dangerous offensive player he has
it back again good work around valeno middle
stad has Skinner in front they can't get it
to him he's on the weak side and he has the puck
now thres it back score what a hockey play Skinner
middle stat Casey sixth of the year and we have
a hockey game at 42 absolutely I said they need
to get one before the 10-minute Mark with 114 40
left that's exactly what they do and it's going
to be petka behind the net here it's a reverse
hit right there knocks ma off the parck gains
possession of it and just a beautiful pass play
skitter to midle stat to the back of the net two
big bodies along the Wall Middle stat is weak side
Puck squirts out and alone to Skinner backand SC
it's a power play goal and the Savers are within
one and it's a big Power Play goal Detroit does
a great job cutting this ice in half keeping
buffalo on the right side but Tage Thompson
back of the lineup great job protecting it and
these are the battles Buffalo has to win they
did it on their last goal they continue do it here
Skinner comes up with that puck what a move to his
backhead Skinner with his 11th of the year we
have a one goal game here bu cousins comes to
darene Middle step one timer blocks wasn't
close empty net to isit Lin he can shoot
it in and he does Dylan lurin ices the game
and with that point he becomes the the 17th
player in Redwing history with 100 career
multi-point games he doesn't get all of it
on this one but it was the block sequence
before that were the biggest and rasmon
stands in there blocks Dalene shot you know
the start of the game they show they can play
that way they have the ability they got to
figure out how to do it for 60 minutes but
what a win by Detroit Weds we mentioned since
returning from Sweden they've been red hot